Now, Marie, in October,
(applause)
you released a new special on BYUtv
called "An Evening with Marie",
and this seems to be like a real celebration
of all the musical chapters in your life.
Will you tell me about that?
Well, I chose, first of all, BYUtv,
I chose it because the app is free and it's on everything.
You can download it anywhere.
And I wanted to do that just because, I mean,
they have over 50 million viewers.
It goes worldwide and the military can get it as well.
It did.
I've always done a lot of things for USO
and people like that, but...
(applause)
But, it's fun, it's an evening with,
and one of the things that I wanted to do,
especially coming out of this pandemic
and people starting to perform again, Drew, is
to me, you know how you play different characters?
I play different vocal styles
and it's been a lifetime of learning how to do it,
from, you know, country to jazz,
to pop to legit soprano, to belt, to operatic.
It's really, really challenging,
and it's been my goal to do that.
So in this show, you're just gonna get a little sampling.
It's not my full symphonic show,
but we have a full symphonic orchestra and music.
When you hear it in that context where everything is live,
it hits everything from your chakras to the tones,
to the lows, to the highs.
And it is so fun. I have video from six decades.
It's just, you'll hear everything that...
I mean, it's a super fun show.
Download it, it's free, and you'll get a little taste
of some of the songs from the album too.
Now, your latest album is "Unexpected".
That is the title. That is beautiful, by the way.
That's, that I...
I have a child calling me on my phone? Hold on.
(Marie laughs)
Okay. There, I've turned it off.
There we go.
I so feel you right now.
I always keep it there in case they need me
and I'll go, are you okay?
Yes. Okay, I'll call you back.
Well, that's depressed...
But anyway, I was in Vegas and my son called me
and I hit, I'll talk to you later.
And then I never did.
(audience sighs)
So, sorry.
No. I, I...
So it's something that is very important to me
to always have my phone on for my children.
I'm so sorry that that happened.
No, you know what?
It's one of those things that you go through.
I lost my son. He was 18.
And I'm really good. I'm okay.
It's just every now and then, you know, people say,
do you ever get over it?
No, you never do.
But God gives you respites and that's...
you hit triggers.
That just happened to be a trigger. Sorry about that.
No, I totally understand.
Yeah.
I really do.
Our lives are full of triggers
and they come up at the most unexpected times,
speaking of the title.
Exactly.
Can I ask if it's possible
to ask you a piece of life advice
that when something does throw you
I know what you're gonna say.
and rock your world, like it just did,
how beautifully you just handled it
and there's people out there,
I'm just wondering if you have any life advice
for how one might be able to handle a trigger.
Ooh, well, I think that God never gives you
anything that you can't handle.
I don't know that God gives them to you,
but I know that people have agency
to make choices that affect you.
And I believe that when life is too much to stand,
I get on my knees and I beg, and I just know,
somehow He gives you that comfort with my son.
You know, a lot of people judged me very harshly
that I went back to work.
You understand that, Drew, you know, you're kind of...
You do everything on a national level
instead of a private level
within your community or whatever.
But I had to choose to go back to work
because I had seven more children that were hurting
and they needed to know that you had to keep living life.
And so, and I felt that was something
that I wanted to do for them,
despite what people were saying.
Thank you.
I'm very, very grateful for your answer and your candor.
And I agree with the fight and I thank you.
(upbeat music)